لجزء من اصوات اقصى اليمين لم يخلوا من
التنازلات في مقطع المصور نشره على صفحته
حذر الاتراك من وصول عشره ملايين اجنبي
حاله فوز اردوغان رغم ان العدد الرسمي حتى
منتصف مايو كان نحو ثلاثه ملايين
اردوغان غير قادر على حمايه الحدود غدا
سيصل عشره ملايين لاجئ وربما 30 مليونا
انهم يشكلون تهديدا لوطننا ان لم نتحرك
لم يذكر مصدر تقديراته لكنه كسب تاييد
المراه التركيه
فضل راي الشاي المهاجرون القادمون الى
بلادنا يحملون نظره سلبيه عن المراه
التركيه هي نظره خاليه من الاحترام
مصدر اخر كنزا من الاصوات من اختار
عدم المشاركه في الجوله الاولى
12% من اصل 64 مليون ناخذ تقريبا اقل من
عشره ملايين من الصعب معرفه توجهاتهم لكن
الطرفين حاول اقناع جزء منهم
يختلف الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ومنافسه
كمال كلجدار اوغلو في كل القضايا تقريبا
فيردوان يريد الابقاء على النظام الرئاسي
مع تعديلات لتجاوز بعض نقاط الضعف بينما
يريد منافسه العوده الى النظام البرلماني
والغاء النظام الرئاسي فيما يخص الاقتصاد
يؤكد انه سيواصل سياسته الراميه لخفض معدل
التضخم وخفض سعر الفائده فيما يعد
باعطاء استقلاليه كامله للبنك المركزي على
صعيد السياسه الخارجيه يرغب اردوغان في
مواصله نهجه المتمثل بالتقارب مع موسكو
دون التخلي عن الغرب والولايات المتحده مع
بقاء نفس السياسه فيما يخص سحب القوات
التركيه من سوريا لكن هذا النهجه يعارضه
زعيم المعارضه الذي يقول انه سيتقارب مع
الغرب اكثر على حساب العلاقات مع روسيا
عدا عن انه يريد تطبيع العلاقات مع دمشق
واعاده اللاجئين في اسرع وقت وسحب الجيش
من شمال سوريا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات